[Music]
have you used the opportunity of having
mark plate as your dad in the show for
him and Kelly to adopt you they're in
the process of adopting me I already
feel like Riverdale star Camilla Mendez
opening up about her cute relationship
with on-screen dad Mark Consuelos and
his real-life wife Kelly Ripa while
chatting with et on the red carpet at
the 2018 MTV movie and TV award like
every time I like have a crush on a guy
and Mark like steps in and like
evaluates ya like work is like my actual
dad in that way ever he's like very
protective and yeah I have to get his
seal of approval and just like a real
dad kamila says Papa Consuelos even has
specific requirements for her potential
suitors just an all-around good guys got
manners gentlemen like the first thing
he said one guy he was like very polite
very polite he likes the honors that the
23 year old actress also gave a sneak
peek of what's to come in season 3 of
their CW show complete with a little
father-daughter drama I can tell you
that Veronica and Hyrum are gonna be
butting heads
I can tell you that there will be more
clear villains and heroes I guess and
I'm hesitant to say anything else
because our showrunner just gave me the
whole spiel and I don't want to say
anything
you